Shinsui and Masanana Street Shinba is a mysterious substance that manipulates special products, so you need to make a contract each time you use more than a certain amount of mold water
.
It's a house. The
other person seems to be the owner, so
please visualize the pocket, close your eyes, and order the lyrics.
I wonder if you're letting me
[Music]
[Music] Because
I want to rape gold, it
's
okay,
but remember,
this isn't a total of 8 copies for you
.  I'm exhausted.
I'm sorry to take a rest and prepare for tomorrow.
I don't apologize for that day.
You also kiss
me. Thank you from tomorrow.
This is laule from the same team. It looks
like it's okay at all. Even though I have a contract, there are a
few 9 people,
so please tell me if you have any serious problems.
Let's help each other. I
don't feel like I can beat these people.  It ’s
not good, so reaching out to the weak is the
weak.